everywhere I go I'm like a magnet for
other guys staring me down oh I'll just
be going about my day and I'll catch eye
contact with another guy and I'll Wonder
Hey why are they staring at me you you
keep looking you never break that eye
contact dude I'll tell you what right
now I [__] look at them this is this
is my advice to you if I ever give good
advice
this is the advice that I give to you in
in Lifeline look at them and when
they're looking at you
imagine yourself eating them
wrong
[Music]
hello hello
recording we are recording we are
recording right now welcome to Lifeline
episode 51 52 what is it I don't know
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday to you
my brother brother Grace
happy birthday
[Applause]
to you
Paul dude how's it feel 43. it feels
good they got me a cake that's amazing
you guys got me a cake I appreciate it I
took a picture of it we'll play it right
here it says life Pips it's so [__]
sloppy a blind person honestly how did
you not get the r that it's so bad you
obviously had it professionally done
right
I was worried that they weren't gonna do
it in time if I asked them to do it so
yeah we had a little cake frosting left
over from the live show
I almost ran out and so I did that I
know it's very sloppy but I almost ran
up there so we didn't have enough for
the extra leg at the R so life Pips yeah
um it smells fantastic I'm gonna eat it
in a little bit here
um and I got
um I uh happy birthday from all you guys
from Chris and Anthony not you didn't
say it yeah and then you got me also
a face mask because you're old now they
want you to lose your wrinkles and [__]
I've never had a face mask before in my
life but I always see Kristin has face
masks and [__] so they're for wrinkles
right
I mean I don't know it's supposed you're
supposed to keep up with it like it's
way too late for me to start now no well
starting it's starting anytime you want
I know my buddy Andy kozell who's been
doing it forever he's been doing like he
does them yeah dude that's hilarious
because he's 65. he looks great no he's
yeah he's 40 something but um it looks
great I got shows uh Hey at this point
we'll be we'll have done Minneapolis the
special
um so yeah hell yeah dude thanks for
coming out Minneapolis it went great
yeah uh so tour tickets at chrisley.com
will be in Columbus and CLE uh no not
Cleveland I will be in Cleveland but I
didn't announce that yet so here we go
oops uh yeah uh Columbus Ohio and
Cincinnati and Milwaukee or no that'll
be old that'll be I have Milwaukee so uh
wait so what am I doing here I'm doing
Tucson Salt Lake City
um Colorado Springs Pueblo and uh Tucson
those are the new ones that we put out
there when you say Tucson do everything
Tucson Arizona no giddy up giddy up
giddy yep
what do you ever think about that what's
ghetto cowboy the song Oh a Crazy Bone
but no no no oh crazy about my favorite
rapper Who's which one's the one that
did ghetto cowboy I think it was Mo
Thugs it was Mo Thugs but who's the one
with the deep voice the bone thug with
the deep voice no no no not busy busy
bones [__] pattern the [__]
Interruption check out his name I don't
know I think he's crazy bone deep bone
um deep voice bone so
so the whole thing is you can get the
merch here the lifeline the purple pen
Matt that Matt's wearing look at that
hoodie it's really nice Christ the way
you're doing it the worst model
on a lazy Susan in the pool in the pool
[Laughter]
dude surfing so so you can go get that
at uh uh lifelinemerch.com or you can go
get sessions with Matt one-on-one
mattelia.com
this much though for real it looks good
on camera but I'm telling you yeah it
feels even better it's nice I mean like
the purple one like I can't wait to see
it on my show so fast I remember if it
doesn't say Micro Machines it's not the
real thing so uh so yeah dude
um uh I thought the rain was gonna stop
didn't stop still was still raining when
we're shooting this today got pissed off
I can't get my car washed dude when's
this time to get car washed I let the
rain do it that's not watching it man
but I let the rain do it I don't ever
get my car washed I mean ever
I don't do it
I I you it's gonna rain I know but at
some point it will rain in L.A it but
yeah but that doesn't mean that you
can't have a nice clean car for like not
you know sometimes it's only for months
it's true the interior in my car folded
every car that I've ever had the
interior is a [__] mess folded caved
you no no I mean that's true I just I
always wait for the rain it's like every
time I [__] get my dog groomed it
rains the next day and then she smells
like [__] ass again right right right
bleep that but she smells like an ass
can you see me say ass you can't say
anything anymore come on YouTube no it's
okay this is Mr Rogers yeah Mr Rogers
tube so um I feel like
I feel like you have to get your car
washed a little bit sometimes okay I you
know every time I go drive by one I
think I should do that I just I never do
it and you don't do it I never do it I
think that uh what I want to know is
people in Seattle I get like I wouldn't
even at that point I would just get a
beater I wouldn't even get a nice car
I mean maybe I would get a nice big car
but like there's [__] no reason to
have a sports car in anywhere where
there's it's raining because it never
looks nice
um you think about that I'm thinking
like having a really cool nice part dude
here's the thing though I'm not the way
you are about cars I know I'm not that
way you're not that way either way you
are I am about things you're not that
way yeah things are not for me like I'm
like wow nice watch never good I got
these glasses the other day love it I
was actually gonna say those are nice
clothes do you like them yeah they're
not expensive or anything I make an
exception for eyewear I do like glasses
because you wear glasses I wear them
yeah yeah gotcha uh because I need to
wear it right right yeah what about
contacts though get the color contacts
Frost yeah that would be sick dude you
would be so sexy what I might do is dye
my hair blonde that might be my next
step in my Evolution what do you think
that is comment on it let me know I
might dye my hair blonde like Kurt
Cobain blonde you know what I was doing
I saw there's this app called lenza is
that what it's called
anyway you put your thing in you could
change everything I was I heard a guy
talking about online so I got it because
I want to do a joke and just send
pictures of myself to everyone actually
I did I made this on it did I send it to
you I don't know let me send it to you
guys and this is where you can post it
but um
and uh and so I wanted to yeah look at
this
you'll see audience it'll be up here now
and so
uh you can make your everything
difficult you can make your cheeks
smaller like chicks use it for you know
what I mean it's called lensa yeah but
chicks use it for um like you know
making it look like they have more of an
hourglass figure and stuff like that
like they post stuff and they look yes
like a Photoshop yeah but like look what
you can do you can do like all sorts of
things it says uh
falling in love wow and that's just a
filter what I want yeah enough to be
looking at no [__] so um I did was
messing around with it and I put my hair
and my hair was Pink on it and I was
like oh maybe I should [__] dye my
hair pink and then I realized I look
like that's that shooter that shot up
the movie theater in Aurora Colorado oh
yeah uh he did yeah James Lipton Peach
did I knew you'd like that man I knew
you'd like that it's so stupid I knew it
why do you like stupid [__] like that
man I've always
it pisses me off when I when I'm
laughing and I say that's so stupid
people are like what do you mean like
you're laughing and I'm like no yeah
that's why I'm saying that's so great
like that's so stupid it's so funny yeah
it's just the dumbest the better you
know dude especially if black people are
like you are like Denny my the guy the
comedian who opens for me on the road he
was like you stupid man and I was like
man that's such a compliment it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I love it we're
black me and you nice is what we're
saying nice you got Alfred's coffee now
what do we agree on that it's bad what'd
you get amazing it's the regular hot
coffee no it's not it's the vanilla
latte world famous vanilla latte that I
get from there okay okay okay well
that's good man yeah I didn't know that
it was I didn't know that you were gonna
do it
we've been thinking about maybe doing an
extra episode or something like that a
month for patreon we were thinking about
flirting with a patreon thing here we're
not sure if we're gonna do it uh but we
do want to maybe do a patreon what are
your ideas man you know somebody's yeah
what are your ideas right right in uh if
you want some more content or whatever
we may do it uh we won't take anything
away but we're probably gonna We may add
some stuff into a patreon would you be
down for that we don't know yeah what it
is now will always be what it is now we
would add extra stuff and I know you
already said that but I'm saying it
better no it's a poetry but I
suggest is you tell us what you want and
then maybe we'll consider doing it but
uh yeah all of our ideas are pretty
boring so give us some good ones they're
like four yeah 40 extra episodes a month
yeah that might not be doable but
something yeah well wow that was that
that sounds so much like I don't know
um I don't know but uh so we'll see what
happens
oh those are shoes and now they're on
the table off of learning English we eat
what's up I don't know what's up with
them oh wait who makes those Balenciaga
nice I knew it I actually knew I thought
you'd like it yeah yeah yeah people are
gonna probably think you uh you know is
Valencia out of the woods yet with their
whole Scandal oh yeah with the good
because that was real dumb and I like
one of my lenses so oh do people say
stuff to you no okay what are you
wearing that dude nobody says anything
to me they're afraid to come up to me on
the street I'm always working like this
well that's bad to do that it's very
unfriendly people some people don't talk
to me I mean you look I hate when
Changers talk to me so I was going
around like this
people approach me anyway yeah they get
closer and I go that's bad about Sling
Blade all right so uh well let's go
let's get into it guys I'm losing my
voice I need to yeah you sound uh
congested well it's just that I'm really
I'm very cool
yeah no it's just early in the morning
what's up guys going for you so I live
with my brother he's 21. he kind of
makes the best roommate in the world
because he never leaves his room but uh
also he never leaves his room right so
all he does is play Xbox he ubereats
every meal wow I can't get him to do
anything we own the house together so
there's a lot to do around the house a
lot of things to fix up and just
maintain I mean
um that's weird I'm kind of worried that
he's gonna turn into a loser if he keeps
this up but then again he's also only 21
so how do I approach this
do I let it ride out do I have like a
sit down with him
um
yeah do I do nothing at all right let me
know that's a really good good question
hey man you got to leave your room no
dude I think that's what you might have
to do you're in your room too much no
you don't say that start leave start
with him leaving the door open a little
bit like baby steps yeah baby steps
like Calvin leave the door open a little
bit it's a good thing you're a good
brother to actually worry about that
because that is a real thing people dude
people complacent some people just I
mean I know you're saying this is what
your brother does but it turns into a
habit and these people just don't leave
their room for like forever yeah like
I've known people who get addicted to
games and they they like don't really go
weeks without leaving their homework
brother did you know that yeah yeah he's
still he's still in the room playing
somewhere yeah it's just uh it's it I
think that honestly you uh
he's 21 it might be okay but here's the
other thing too is like coven messed it
up for a lot of people like so now for
the past three years I'm sure he got
used to doing that because he had to and
now he's [__] stuck so it's a bit of
a cycle of like you know what I mean
he's addicted to the lifestyle yeah he's
addicted to the game you know I mean the
actual little game if he's literal game
if he's playing video games wow God
[__] up so many people's lives
remember all our friends that lost our
minds yeah I'm addicted to the game dude
I'm addicted to the game okay okay I'm
sympathetic to those people who lost
their minds you know
um what what because it did the Tupac
thing yeah so to the gang I think uh but
Bill Clinton what you just did
oh
no way dude I was listening to Tupac the
other day God damn he really is so good
I was like why don't I listen to him
more you don't hear my favorite you know
that of course yeah but like why don't I
why don't I listen to him more oh dude
it pisses me off so much what how you
are about getting out of a car when a
Tupac song is playing it used to be like
that nothing made me more mad about
anything you ever did than that he used
to never get if we arrived somewhere and
it was time to get out of the car when a
two box song was playing he'd have to
wait till the song ended
to be paying respect to Tupac God bless
the dweeb okay um didn't Bill like yell
at him once yeah dude of course that's
so funny he was like we gotta go to
[__] dinner and I'm like I can't
there's the two parties
wow wow dude and he was like everyone's
[__] wait for you everyone was in the
car like this yeah look at looking at me
in my car and I was like
and then finally I was like fine I
turned it off I felt so bad to remember
that so so that made me feel bad during
the whole dinner well he should have
made you feel bad because that's idiotic
that was the first time I ever did that
in my life
this is the first time I ever did that
Milan
why are you Southern right there but
dude it's so he's so good dude dad uh so
wait this guy though
you gotta you you have to talk to him
about it and even if obviously you
should start by being like hey like
let's do this let's do that let's do
that and even if you have to guilt him
into it it doesn't matter still do it if
he's not coming out of his room even
when you ask him to or tell him to to
tend to real life [__] then you gotta
have a real talk like man-to-man taco
and be like yo I know you're young
you're 21 but that you're not 12. you're
an adult now you got to act like one you
got to live in the world you can play
your video games in downtime but you
gotta also live in the world with other
human beings more than anything else
we're social animals you can't just be
alone all the time the God just be like
I don't have to leave but he does why
because he's going to get mad depressed
he's probably gonna have to start
getting like health problems and [__]
because you need to be outside to be
healthy you also need to be in
communication with other people in
person to be healthy that's a real thing
it sounds like mumbo jumbo [__] but
you need to be social and not on your
[__] headset while you're playing
holy Warcraft or whatever the [__] holy
Warcraft dude
holy Warcraft world of holy world craft
the worst title of any actually holy
worker holy Warcraft sounds sick yeah I
would go see a movie with holy Warcraft
yeah who's he who's holy Warcraft uh
yeah no that's under Warcraft that would
be a good uh good video game holy
Warcraft the PO you're the pope yep yeah
and you have to use a gun even though
you don't want to because it's sinning
but you have to right right right right
right right but also uh the pope is uh
hospitalized you read about this because
he's so sick yeah because yeah because
with that drip with the jacket dude dude
it's not real
how [__] and fooled did you get though
I did
thought it was real hey I do it for me
dude
real close in and look at the hands
we're all so far I know I know life's
over yeah
dude it's not even exactly it's just
that this is the tip of the [__]
Iceberg AI is here just to [__] Rule
and I mean think about like presidential
like speeches like I mean we're just
we're done we're done we're done
you know what I I the video I watch
these videos
um of all these Boomers like they get
scammed online oh yeah it's kind of like
catfish but it's an online show a scam
fish yeah yeah you know you love it I
love it and these old people
their brains are
we as younger people are like oh they're
so dumb they're not dumb their brains
are just not ready for what the internet
had to offer right they're not they're
not they're brain like they're not their
brains are done forming right and they
can't do it they cannot right figure it
out that that is a scammer that the
person on the other side of this is not
that super sexy man with the [__]
stubble beard who's like looking at the
camera with the rose like it's some guy
in Nigeria yeah just like on a headset
doing this to 20 other people at the
same time yeah dude you know man would
you I'd be I bet I would get I would be
so
I bet I would love that job okay but
real quick okay my point was that's
going to be us with AI like we are so
not ready to have a world where AI is so
prevalent we're all going to be like
those old people who are [__] idiots
scammed by Nigeria like the kids are
gonna grow up and just be like they're
gonna literally see a video and they're
gonna be like well who knows if that's
real their default is like and ours is
like
you know like the black mirror right
wasn't that the one where he [__] the
pig oh right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the first episode yeah okay
I mean you know it's the first episode
okay dude I saw that show rabbit hole
don't know what you don't with key for
Sutherland and oh I saw an ad for it I
don't know the show though bro you know
you see that [__] ad for that show
and I'm like is it 24 basically you know
I see that I'm like uh dude my nights
are they're done for now I'm gonna watch
the whole thing so basically it's kind
of like that like getting too close to
me yeah do with the I with the AI and
like they put stuff in and they they
scam people that way and
um and I watch two whole episodes and I
and I don't have a [__] dude it was
so bad dude oh really it's so bad that
even I can't watch it it's so bad that
um
what do you call it I was watching it
and they tried it it's a little bit like
24 in the in the suspense style not the
keepers in it so yeah 24 yeah yeah if he
wasn't there I wouldn't think that but
right
um but dude it literally they try to
have humor in it which is so weird if
you talk about it yeah yeah okay yeah
but they try to have like banter oh yeah
where they're like
it's very 30 years ago that that kind of
thing yeah dude it's like you make
they're like they're like that's not the
face you're supposed to make if you're
doing this and like not that's not a
line but like that's the style and
you're just like oh they're bantering
it's like [__] George Costanza should
be
uh yeah what's it about though
you don't even know dude how could it
exist and nobody knows what the shows
are it I watched two episodes so he
basically
um gets a job to try and he has to like
get two people together and have it look
like they're colluding so they can take
a picture oh okay so he he does this
whole [__] thing where he's like all
right we're gonna pick the person up and
pretend we're a Cabbie and then all
right yeah yeah in the wrong way and
then wow wow sounds like somebody
dropped something they pick up and give
it to the other one shot what's it on uh
permanent plus oh okay which I like I
like purple I do too but uh you know why
American animals aren't Paramount it is
yeah
Paramount plus American animal it's the
only place to stream it in its finest
form
so also the Beavis and Butthead movies
on there so let's go I have to watch the
old one no the new new that's not a
movie it's a series no it's a movie it
is yeah I have to watch it [__]
hilarious okay cool so anyway uh is a
bit off the rails of the podcast so
um he does that and then at the end of
the first episode I'm not ruining it
because the first episode of Pilots what
it's about
um you find out that
the guy that he tried to set take the
picture with and the woman they die
and everyone thinks it's him because he
did all this because he did all this
[__] and it's like was I set up by the
dude and then at the end of the episode
he goes home and the God this is so
weird the guy who he took was in the
picture that was dead is now at his
house all tied up and keep yourself
looking I'm eating an apple what
that's not good we're gonna go with
another idea but thanks for coming in so
do you want to buy it 20 million so dude
that's the every episode costs three
million either so dude and then the
second episode is just like more of that
and I'm just like you know what I
actually can't do this sounds a little
too heady yeah yeah but also that with
Kiefer Sutherland that doesn't sound
like the right mix yeah keeper something
is like for dumb shows I know like dumb
Minds you know in the good way I know
yeah yeah popcorn but this is maybe that
but but just biting off a little bit
more that it can chew you know okay okay
well don't watch Rabbit Hole watch
American animal on Paramount plus uh
yeah you got to talk to your [__]
loser ass brother okay what's next oh
well I'm losing my voice crate hey Chris
and Matt love the podcast Chris we saw
you in Lakeland you were phenomenal Matt
you're awesome thank you uh my name is
Amanda I'm a middle school art teacher I
work in a K-8 and here's my problem my
classroom next door neighbor is the
elementary school teacher this guy has
no boundaries he comes in my classroom
all the time unannounced he gives me way
information more information about his
personal life than I would ever need and
recently I found out he's been stealing
my lesson plans so the first time I
called him out and he just like acted
like it was a coincidence he had no idea
and then I found another one of my
projects that he's doing and the issue
is that his fifth graders this year are
going to come to me next year are going
to be like we've already done this so
I'm just wondering if you have any
advices what should I do let me know
thanks okay that's the kind of situation
you gotta rat his ass out that's you got
to ride his ass out you confronted him
he didn't want to confess he doesn't
want to do the right thing by
confronting yeah you got to ride his ass
out go to the principal straight up
doesn't matter and if he's like how
could you do that to me like what do you
mean no you didn't stop when I
confronted that's a rat
unless you say yo I'm gonna have to
[__] go above you if you don't stop
so you think she should talk to him one
more time and say that I don't like
being a rat but he that guy's putting
her in her awful position that's what
I'm saying you can't
she can't win without an appeal to
Authority if you're just going to keep
doing it right nobody's going to know if
she doesn't say something and then she's
going to look bad because or rather
she's going to have to do extra work
right and she does have to say something
because honestly
it's directly accepting Dumber it's also
directly affecting her work and making
her do more work in the long run so say
if you don't stop I'm gonna have to rat
you out and then if he still does it rat
him out
yeah or write him out honestly yeah I
mean I wouldn't you already gave him a
shot yeah exactly that's what I think
they're not you're not in any sort of
wrong dude that's wild if you want to do
extra like given the benefit of doubt
you can warn him one more time but I
yeah I would definitely not you already
did uh I want to know how you prove that
someone is stealing your lesson talk to
the kids no I I understand but like how
do you know that I'm sure like
it's kind of the same [__] you have
there's curriculum okay
prove it not how do you prove it but how
do you even know how are you so [__]
sure he's stealing the list but how do
they differ how much do they differ to
where it's like do you know what I'm
saying I don't I I'm assuming she has
more than just like a hunch though
but what I'm saying is lazy guy dude
clean my we got dirty so what I'm saying
is though is like in a lesson plan
uh like you have to go over what World
War One World War II [__] if it's
history
how do you say you stole that you
understand what I'm saying I do but that
what is the lesson plan because it's
more specific than just World War one
it's a specific lesson and exercise and
class project
yo I had them do a poster board of
[__] you know the Spanish Inquisition
right this guy's doing a push-up Board
of the Spanish that's not what it is
that's not what they're doing but yeah
well how do you know that
because she teaches k through eight
she's not teaching about the Spanish
Inquisition you know what's the Spanish
Inquisition yeah yeah what's a bayonet
well
you can impale someone with it
[Applause]
yeah no they're not learning about that
yeah if at all all right okay so do that
yep
um
hey Chris hey Matt I just want to get
your guys's opinion on your friends
dating yours ex-girlfriends uh what you
guys think about that is that crossing
the line
or whatever
um
kind of confused right now just because
I have that going on in my life my one
of my friends is let me know that he's
going to be in a relationship with one
of my ex-girlfriends and uh is that like
bro code or or what
um let me let me know what you guys
think uh Chris I'll see you April 1st
Minneapolis hey peace I'll be there too
666 christa.com dude I have a specific
opinion about this but go ahead I think
you should get over it bro try to get
over it because there's no nobody nobody
any good of course try to get over it
but my yeah right but if it's really
here's the thing if if it was a very
recent relationship then there's a real
issue with that what's up with that
friend yeah that's not a good friend no
it's [__] up uh and but assuming it's
been ample time
if you're still upset about it
that's kinda on you it's still very
annoying but like you gotta roll with
the punches and let it go if it's been
like two years bro but also here's the
thing it's good for you if it bothers
you because you still like her or
whatever
then it's good anyway to act like you
don't care
so either act like you don't care or
don't care either one is good but why is
it good for him to act like he doesn't
care because it certainly isn't good for
him to act like he cares well unless
he's like you know what [__] my friend I
don't want to have anything to do with
him and that's [__] of my ex and I'm
not speaking them ever again
we I guess you could also do that that's
good for him well yeah but I'm saying if
you like want right to engage in
Friendship Warfare
the best uh route is just a bye yeah bye
bye
Tata
clicking of your rings
what else is there no so konnichiwa
whatever the [__] no that just I think
that's hello
um that's a low um so also it should
just be mushy huh
Moshi
I like mushy well sometimes it sounds
like that kind of say it fast you know
uh yeah all right look so I think that
honestly the time is a big factor like
if it's yeah a month that's [__] of
him you know because also if it's a
month it's also longer than a month
that's the thing they've been lying to
you for a little bit you got to know
that well no here's the thing though if
it's been a long time and like you said
your friend came to you and was like hey
I wanted to let you know yeah then he
kind of did it right he did do it right
he came correct if you found out about
it and then the friend was like ah
um yeah I'm sorry man I I wanted to tell
you but didn't know how like that that's
shitty but if the friend was Eve had to
not courtesy but like
your friend respects if he comes to you
and says look I know you guys had a
relationship but like her and I know
each other and I don't know what's going
on but like I really want to take her
like you know whatever on a date or I
really want to start dating her and I
just want to let you know you know it's
not like he's asking you he doesn't have
to ask you but he's doing the right
thing by coming to you and telling you
that this is what he plans on doing I
don't think that you have
very Solid Ground to stand on to be
legit pissed unless again unless it was
very recent uh and I'm talking like
within a year I think a year is a year
is a good Benchmark yeah
um but you know
it's a tough thing I don't care if my my
buddies go out with my exes but like
I don't know it is weird though
I'm like
stuff doesn't bother me like I'm a
Stonewall you know how nice okay well
yeah I'm a real man I mean like I know
it's cool to like show your emotion but
like when I need to bro yeah I can just
be a [__] Stonewall okay well that's
actually not good nothing bothers me
it's not good so you're gonna get an
also when I love getting murdered in
front of me honestly go about my day if
I need to right okay because I I've
you're a terrible person no it's like
you know Jason stayed them in the
beginning of movies that's what I'm like
I'm familiar oh right before he gets
like talked back into caring about stuff
100 I don't do that man yeah yeah no
that's not for me I just murder like and
then like a little Chinese girl arrives
oh yeah and he's like you remind me of
my daughter she died
yeah ah [__] now I'm all conflicted and
[__] well we're script worst script ever
[__] now someone kidnapped her ah for
[__] sake
[__] God damn it imagine if there
really was a script like time to go into
the basement and [__] hit the button
and have the walls all open up and have
there be [__] 165 million guns that I
haven't used cut
Jason's ad-libbing again you're blowing
it we have the shot already we shot that
scene and you're blowing it he doesn't
need to say it all right
so I'll Rambo the other night which what
Rambo last blood
last Blood the last one the very last
one wow would Stallone's like 74. dude
you know I love Stallone yeah I know
that he's a bud he is a butt of yours
okay yeah love Stallone he was gangster
in that movie
yeah he's a [__] Rambo of course he
was but it's more gangsters 75 and he's
just dude he's barely he's so talk about
Stone Cold like me yeah okay dude
hey no you do it no no no no I don't
know
oh okay okay
dude he pulled out a guy's heart in the
movie come on cut it out
cut it out or pulled it out cut
goes like this with the knife and then
goes why pulls it up because he wanted
the guy to know that that's how it feels
that's that that happened to him first
well and metaphorically it happened to
him because he lost someone that was
like a daughter to him that's so stupid
because people talk about Broken Hearts
like it's not literal
when your daughter dies you go ah you
know what I mean ah my heart broke it
wasn't for him though he said this is
how it feels and he was going like this
and the guy was just like ah because he
was because before that he took [__]
bow and arrows and he stuck up
okay
okay good acting way far away that was
good acting but how I did it yeah
because like I wasn't mine yeah yeah it
was good it was good stop making me have
to repeat it yes it was good because of
can you just say though because of how I
because of how your body did in the
sound effects and all that it was clear
yeah okay so he's like that and then he
go and then he [__] hops down walks
across the barn and goes this is how it
feels and he just goes let's give him
the worst HJ of all time just and he
goes and he goes and I'm watching it
with um
Dave's and Kristen awake still
no it was uh so it's not because that
was happening no Sam cheek no Sam my
videographer oh Sam and he says take a
bite dude if he took a bite it would
have gone from a movie that I simply had
seen two top 10 movies of all time I've
ever seen right if at the end he goes
and eats the heart
come on bro I don't know if that would
be good but okay I I understand that you
would love it all right yeah yeah it's
already ridiculous it's got the heart
out if it really went for it dude
there's too many rambos and then and
then all of a sudden like after that a
Mexican dude it cuts him and he goes
adios like oh the greatest movie of all
time it's like an SNL sketch yeah
all right well I don't even remember
what the question was yeah I don't
either but that's definitely you should
not eat somebody's heart I think that
someone's heart out oh the boyfriend
that's the answer girlfriend all right
friends yeah and then if he does that to
you he could do that yeah if he does
that to you be like this how it feels
and then cut his heart out take out but
this time take a bite out of it okay but
now if the guy takes that advice and
does that then you were like culpable so
to do the thing in the beginning of the
thing was like all right right you know
like not there yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
so we're good we're good I think we're
good all right who's next
hey Chris hey Matt love the show I think
you guys are really funny the way you
interact with each other hates us so my
issue is everywhere I go I'm like a
magnet for other guys staring me down oh
I'll just be going about my day and I'll
catch eye contact with another guy and
I'll Wonder Hey why are they staring at
me and all of a sudden now I'm in this
dominance game of staring contest no get
out of here and I'm like this is so
stupid
and I always look away right then I feel
weak no no I don't know I just got
dominated no so it's like I keep staring
and I'll probably wind up in a fight and
if I look away I feel weak no so it's
wondering what do you guys do when that
happens and no they're not staring
because of the sweater I don't usually
wear this all right okay yeah you you
keep looking you never break that eye
contact dude I'll tell you what right
now dude when people stare at me I was
joking around I said I would do that too
I would not do that do when people stare
at me I [__] look at them this is
this is my advice to you if I ever give
good advice okay this is the advice that
I give to you in in Lifeline look at
them and when they're looking at you
imagine yourself eating them
consume them eat them eat their imagine
eating their face working your way down
from the neck to the shoulders then
eating their chest and Tommy imagine
like Pac-Man eating their you know [__]
balls take some time at the [__] right I
mean to eat it just [__] make it nice
you know
right and then you know all the way down
and then and then and and and as you're
watching them you get lost in this world
of I'm eating this [__] and you
don't even think about the fact that
you're there staring and you'll win
because they'll be like uh
who are these people engaging in staring
contests in the world what if this guy's
just he doesn't know but he's walking
around just like well that that was one
of my two thoughts is like maybe it's in
your head now so you're engaging it and
you're triggering it like I one time I
thought this guy was following me when I
was driving around and because I thought
he was following me I like started kind
of following him okay and then he
stopped and he was like why the [__] you
found me I was like
[__] oh that's hilarious you know like
what a dumbass you know
um look maybe this guy here look at me
like maybe this guy is doing what I'm
doing like be looking at me watch
what's up like that's you know you never
know you know the other thing I thought
is maybe people
are like attracted to him yeah maybe
he's like maybe honestly maybe his
prototype is a gay guy's dream and he's
just that's right exactly honestly a gay
guy I know rather well looks exactly
like him
and it might be like you've not realized
it but you've dipped into like gay
looking territory oh you know he does
look pretty clean and yeah like very
with the sweater I know he doesn't
always wear the sweater but if he's
wearing [__] like the sweater made me
think that he had a really manicured
beard maybe like like
Edge out like look at edgier you know
that looks sloppier yep and I bet it'll
happen less get some [__] get a neck
tattoo you know what I mean maybe do it
like me as long as it's the right thing
yeah because nobody thinks I'm gay and
dude and that will be okay
people used to think I was gay way more
than they do now I had a guy one time
get in a cab with me in New York when I
flagged it down I got in and this dude
just opens the door slides in with me
he's like where do you want to go I was
like get stuff [__] out of here wow even
if you were gay like to sit let's go
forward and surprising like hey where
you want to go to be like wow my house
yeah no it might have not been the right
move even if I don't yeah I don't uh
I've the the amount I've been hit on by
gay guys is so little yeah you don't
seem very good okay yeah I was gonna ask
that because I mean I'm talking about
hmm
it's been
so minimal I can't even believe it maybe
you're really ugly to gay guys no
because I've been hit on by guys okay
but I don't think I seem very I mean
maybe I do I don't know but me I I'm I'm
a good looking I got some [__] going on
right now I don't think gay guys would
like you what yeah I think you guys
would like me a lot more you think
though that [__] and talk about who you
like more
all right so now that you said that it's
gonna be [__] they're gonna say you
but if I'll take you to gay City like I
straight up
and you know I know we joke around a lot
but like I'll I will I would be really
good at doing all the gay stuff so now
let's say it
but we can't say it on the podcast but
you know what I'm talking about so
you're saying you would be good at being
gay
BJ's so and also just kind of taken care
of Okay so
are you gay no but if I if I was I would
really go into it you'd be careful you'd
be killing it yeah dude because you know
me man oh all of a sudden oh I got you
know I started getting tattoos I got all
the tattoos right you know yeah
mentality yeah yeah bro I mean the other
day there's another one too oh I started
shopping getting stuff I couldn't stop
bro I'm not a terrible thing to me I
told you how bad I felt after I was
shopping I didn't realize you spent too
much
well what's too much I don't know
probably what you did maybe yeah yeah I
don't know but I just like and in my
head I was like I'll buy it I'll wear it
on stage it's okay and then I'm like I
left and I was like what am I doing I
got green pants those pants are actually
kind of cool they are gangster dude yeah
they look like the Riddler though kind
of which is fine but which is fine but I
didn't get the jacket that goes with it
then that would have been terrible and
there was also a hat with a big question
mark
all right well the guy yeah maybe first
what I would say is definitely you
looking away is not you backing down and
being weak you're looking at ways
spending your time better spending your
time doing something else rather than
looking at dudes like why would you want
to do that you're not you're not gaining
anything like what you're gonna what if
the other guy looks away you oh oh you
won
are you a [__] loser either way dude
you should go like this you should keep
looking at him and when he looks away
even though he doesn't see you he hears
you go yes
dude I described that really good and
funny oh okay well I'm glad you thought
so but okay I think you did all right
next
hey uh Chris
I'm your brother Matt
yeah what's up question I love this guy
what do you guys do when uh
your friend likes a girl but the girl
actually likes you oh no
oh came that came so hard at the end
that was the last guy on the planet that
looks like he would have a nose ring too
that guy killing it you know like I
reminded me of is Chris Moog Marco
yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah Chris Christmas
um uh well we love to smoke um dude
that's a that is a good question
I think you don't do anything unless you
have feelings for the girl then then
everything's way complicated but if you
just happen to know a girl likes you
and if you're just trying to get
horizontal no no if you have
no I'm just saying if a girl happens to
know if you happen to know a girl likes
you but your friend likes that girl and
you're the only one that knows both of
those things
bye I see what you're saying I don't
necessarily disagree with that I don't
get involved but if you have feelings
for her then there's a whole Tango
coming and you better [__] straighten
it out with your friend before anything
happens yeah because that's like that's
direct falling out [__] yeah so yeah if
you don't have feelings for her don't no
hard enough don't say [__] but if you do
you're going to want to address it with
your buddy before anything happens yeah
damn it's crazy that is wild how that
[__] happens that happens all the time
five years ago the same people five
years ago I would have [__] the woman
and also the man oh yeah you're just
sounding more and more gay as The Show
Goes On okay you said because I went
shopping no because you said you [__]
a guy five years ago
uh
but it's all good yeah dude uh yeah
if you don't have feelings for just
leave it entirely alone if you do
and you plan on acting on it definitely
talk to your friend first because that
[__] gets so sticky so fast yeah and
talk about staring contests like that is
not I don't if I have so if I was in a
situation where I liked a girl and the
girl liked someone else which I suppose
has happened before right never happened
to me but I to be honest I don't
remember a time where that's happened
I'm sure it's happened right
to you too no that's not me but uh if
it's happening you I could maybe
remember but
um
so I I I don't imagine what I would do
like I guess if I liked a girl and she
liked someone else that was my friend I
guess that would
it would be a thing that I would be like
I would have to get over right yeah but
who cares because if someone doesn't
like you then well that is of the mind
that I am like who gives a [__] like if
somebody doesn't like me then I'm like
oh well then what do you care I don't
like them who else but also like
if someone doesn't like you who do you
care that they end up with like they're
they're not you're not going to end up
dating them so like they could end up
dating somebody you'd never met your
[__] second cousin it doesn't matter
but you're talking as a cool guy that
has options okay fair enough you know
what I mean like some guys are just like
right but that man this is the girl I
like but that mindset is important
either way you're right and helpful
either way you're right and it helps to
have that mindset so yeah you know
whether you have tons of options or zero
options it helps to have that mindset
right true but what she is with the girl
I like
yo how about this how about this I saw
her first oh the worst dude
I saw first it's actually genuinely
sexist because it's taking the agency
away from the freaking woman like it
only she's just like there yeah and
whoever actually literally laid eyes on
her first that's all that matters like
what about what she wants yeah that
counts that counts yeah
yeah uh but yeah no uh it's just uh
don't let it get sticky if if you have
no feelings in the first place then who
cares it does seem like he has no
feelings yeah but he is calling in
though true so he might have feelings
all right well next one I like him
though yeah he is I like his angle I
like his nose ring hey Matt and Chris so
what's up dude last week I was staying
at a resort with my girlfriend of course
you were who was attending a conference
with her co-workers and I hadn't met her
co-workers yet and I was not attending
the cops this is such a good voice so
during the conference her co-workers
kept asking her like oh when are we
gonna when are we gonna meet your
boyfriend oh boy and an inside joke
developed between them where they would
refer to me as something that's not my
name
but starts with the first letter of my
name so like a different name entirely
or like a noun a random object sure so
my girlfriend told me this and I'm like
okay whatever I don't care yeah of
course but then
we were at a party on the last night of
the conference and I finally met
everyone and we're all sitting down at a
table and they start this inside joke
where they're calling me by something
that's not my name oh that's so and I
didn't laugh because I didn't think it
was funny also why would you laugh
anyway and like you know I wanted them
to like me but I'm not gonna laugh at
something in which they're making fun of
my name just so that they like me
but like it got awkward after that so I
don't know I just wish there was
something that I could have said that
would have been funny but then also
would have put them in their place
because
like if you want to talk to me call me
by my name and if you're not going to
I'm not going to talk to you wow so
deeper let me know what you guys think
we're getting to the root of the problem
his dad called him boy a lot you know
hey boy
I don't know what do we think I mean I
think first of all Let It Go bro
it it's not as serious as that at first
I kind of was like with him and then I
was like oh I'm deeper yeah I'm with
them until he starts carrying that they
called him that it's not that you
shouldn't care that they called you
about that but you don't have to laugh
at you shouldn't feel like you have to
laugh because all that is is Annoying
It's also they shouldn't expect you to
laugh because it's not you're you're not
on the inside of that joke yeah and also
it's not funny
yeah there's nothing funny about it you
you have to laugh but I mean I have a
feeling like if it got awkward if it got
awkward
then he wasn't just not laughing right
he was like fuming he was like
my name's Steve and they're calling me
sax okay
my name's not Sox my name's nuts Simba
okay that's great great I'm glad
everybody's having a great time except
me uh anyway I'm Steve or he goes funny
yeah right yeah
yeah I mean I guess I guess my name's
Sunset now huh guys
what it might have been is like so
awkward it wasn't so awkward but his
girlfriend was like why didn't you laugh
when they said that goodbye because
women like to complain and then also
have the you know make it about no no no
no because she wanted it to go over and
everybody be friends with everybody
and City for you and uh yeah
I don't know man let it go let it go let
it go and it's not my name he was just
like and I you know and they're not
saying my name and I just don't think
it's funny and it got real awkward and
so like just [__]
fuming
you just don't like I didn't eat at all
you know I haven't slept in days the
whole time food just piled on just
yeah it's good food
I'll try to take a video of it next time
yeah it's not gonna happen again no no
no no no not with this world famous
podcast oh not with the reaction that it
had he had I don't think they're gonna
do it again yeah true right right right
right you know they're all scared of
them [__] you know
he has a great voice though you should
have like a radio show or something that
guy's got a good voice
you know what do radio fine
do radio his voice is fine you know that
thing he's got a face for radio yeah
that's not what I meant
okay don't take it this guy seems
sensitive I don't want him to think yeah
he's ugly so I was on he calls into
[__] bad friends so I was on another
podcast and they told me to uh to do
radio is it because I'm ugly I mean it's
fine I just got real awkward afterwards
after they said that I was in my car
just alone kind of like
all right all right
mattress I needed places
I absolutely love this podcast it is
never not funny and the energy between
the two of you is oh immaculate
so I recently made the decision to
pursue my doctorate in experimental
psychology I'm currently 28 years old
another seven years of school wow very
cool um I
went back to grad school late
so
taking out student loans right now at
this particular point in time is dumb
okay however that being said I feel like
I finally found the path that I want to
go down I love what I'm studying I'm
good at it
and there is a demand for this
particular field okay but I cannot seem
to get over the fact that it means I
have to slide into even more debt that I
am currently in just to finish this and
I know that if I keep this mindset
I'm not going to get through this
program I have a very very long road
ahead of me
so I could do some motivation if you're
up for it and any words of wisdom you
have to offer in terms of reframing this
in a more positive mindset long term I
could really hear right now too so
thanks love you both all right you would
say you're let's let's just say your
fifteen thousand dollars in debt now and
if you take out student loans to finish
this seven year program of experimental
psychology I think is what she's done
right uh then at the end of that you'll
be fifty thousand dollars yeah I'm just
pulling right
and then let's say you don't do it
and
in seven years you've paid off that
fifteen thousand dollars but
it's just seven years have passed and
you aren't
[__] yeah that you want to be it's
always better to be once you graduate
you can get a [__] sick ass job as
someone with a degree in experimental
psychology and pay off 50 whatever
thousand dollars it is way easier than
you could probably pay fifteen thousand
dollars off now because you have a
[__] degree
Department like you can do [__] with
that degree yeah uh and also it's seven
years if you don't do it you're gonna
look back and be like ah what is debt
who cares money's just money like I I
should have done the thing that I wanted
to do as far as I see it you don't have
a choice you have to do that it's in
front of you it's what you want to do
it's what you can do and all you got to
do is go deeper into debt to get it like
it's worth it that is worth it that
things cost good things cost
valuable prices for a reason
uh and this is just the cost of doing
business to get what you want in this
department do it good things cost
valuable prices
um I think a jeweler you know
um I think that the energy of which you
started talking about it to the energy
of which you ended in the video was
drastically different and it's because
of one thing you became a little bit
negative while you were talking the
positivity that you radiate and then
jubilant nature that you have
um is what's going to propel you and get
you through all of everything that you
need to and I don't know what the
Market's like in the job search of
experimental uh psychology she said it's
like a it's a it's a market that like
needs people to have degrees well I've
had experimental psychology right or
Psychiatry and um you know I know that
the the people out there you would have
you're at least your Vibe would I would
have really been it would have been
welcome
um because not everybody's like that
there are a lot of good people that go
into this field because whether it's the
people that I've I've uh yeah
yeah yeah exactly
um
so I you know yeah I think Matt's point
is probably the best point I mean
[Music]
um
the alternative is the school I mean
that sucks man you know and I don't know
how easy it is for you to pay it off per
month or whatever it is per year but
it'll be easier once you're on the
[__] degree that's Redemption right
and if if the job is in demand and if
it's going to be in demand and whenever
you're done then and if you think that
that looks promising then I say you do
it yeah dude yeah remember when you
called me a jeweler I just didn't
appreciate it uh and I didn't laugh and
I don't know I don't know what it's
going to be like man I don't know what
it's going to be like moving forward
with you as much it'll be fine probably
I can't be home 43. you want to try some
of this cake or not sure live Pips yeah
live Pips but don't we fly high look how
I do it I'm looking a little bit further
with the fork and infomercial oh I see
yeah just like that we're able to make a
nice clean piece of cake how much would
a thing that cuts cake really
efficiently be a thing that there's an
infomercial for oh yeah
what's good is that we have plates you
know what I'm talking about no oh yeah
we don't
oh that's the piece I want too I was
gonna grab it for me but it's all good
where's my piece
was it good yeah well here's the thing
about you you don't usually like things
that are good you like shitty things
this is good or this is like the kind of
shitty thing you like
you're gonna like it so it's not good
you don't like it no yeah okay I knew it
yeah okay
all right you're here
let's see if I'm right
oh wow stab in the back your throat
well that's sweet that's good though
yeah it's pretty sweet yeah
you know it's 6 a.m right now but yeah
and then you got me this
is so heavy yeah it looks heavy it's
always like a bulletproof vest I need to
get one of those
a bulletproof face mask why don't they
have those oh yeah I thought it was
gonna be like come on bro well you're
not supposed to open them it's you're
ready you're all like [__] squirty
they're supposed to be he said pry it on
oh
hey look squirty you know try it on
let's walk right up
they're like wet naps and [__] right oh
dude I thought that was a
I thought it was like a coveted face
mask no uh oh wow dude this entire time
I was like why'd you get him a face mask
that's so stupid dude wow Anthony's
laughing I'm getting pissed off looking
at you open dude it's so hot
don't put it on your sunglasses on yeah
so I'll have to well now my hands are
all wet can you do it
piano I get a breakout and I'm gonna
break out we have a [__] red rash
oh my god oh Hannibal Lecter straight up
okay this straight up does nothing I
there's no way there's no there's no way
that does [__]
against your face
smells really good though
okay well now you have 29. enjoy them
yeah ew yeah dude it looks bad it even
looks disgusting on your hand when you
have the liquid on it you dude this
thing sucks dude you got all of your
face now it looks like you got [__]
just see jabby all over there
I gotta wash my face all right yeah
let's end the show uh thanks everybody
for uh coming on the lifeline we love
you happy Birthday Chris thanks and then
also come see me in Ohio hopefully the
rash will be gone by then of course
today.com uh mattelier.com if you want
uh one on one with me
privacy guaranteed and we got the new
merch the lifelinemerch.com and if you
have a question uh click the link below
or what's the other way to do it uh ask
Lifeline ask Lifeline ask lifeline watch
lifeline.com uh thank you everybody uh
hopefully Chris doesn't have a rash for
his big special coming up in a couple
days and
and next time you see you he will have
shot his special oh and look here he is
do you want to say something before we
go yeah I got a little bit of that stuff
in my eye and now I can't really see
okay now we can't see so I'll be
rewinding so much rash when I shoot this
so far okay
uh we got the new merch buy your purple
before it goes out a bit out of stock it
goes out of business guys no that's uh
it's gonna be the hot seller all right
uh uh I love you guys basement see you
next week
[Music]